all right, let's get into audience questions
for the week.
Sort of the last time, the last time that
it's for the Friday show, we will take more
audience questions, but next week we've got
a weird schedule because
holiday anyway, who cares?
This is one of the last times we'll be taking
audience questions for the year and the first
question is, Hey David, why can't Baron Trump
ever be mentioned publicly according to Republicans,
but it's fine for Trump to uh, attack a Gretta
tune Berg grit attuned brick of course time's
person of the year, the European climate activists,
a 16 or 17 year old climate activist.
So I agree with you, it makes no sense that
merely mentioning Baron is off limits, but
the president himself is going after this
young girl who's a climate activist.
Now when I tweeted about this, I got a bunch
of tweets from right-wingers saying, David,
don't you understand the difference?
Gretta tune Berg is a public figure by choice.
She is an activist.
She is doing something and opening herself
up to criticism.
Baron is just the president's son.
He has not done anything publicly.
He is not trying to be in the public eye.
That's why it's unfair to mention Baron.
But Gretta Toon Berg is a willing public figure
and therefore she can be attacked.
Listen, what was mentioned about Baron Trump
was literally a word pun.
It wasn't about Baron Trump, a professor law
professor Carlin who testified in the house,
impeachment hearings a couple of weeks ago
in talking about how the president Donald
Trump has a desire for unchecked power similar
to that of a Monarch.
She said, Baron Trump can't also be a Baron,
right?
So like B a, R, O, N, the low level, um, uh,
ma figure of a monarchy.
It's some kind of Royal position, right?
Uh, a bar, BA, R, O, N, lowercase, not a proper
noun.
It's just a word, pun.
Okay.
And Republicans went crazy.
Like Baron Trump as an individual was being
attacked in some way.
It's just a language convenience.
That's all it is.
There was no actual criticism of Baron.
The criticism is of Donald Trump who has children,
the adult ones who have just been installed
in positions of notoriety, privilege and power
without being elected, without being confirmed
by the Senate.
And that is the problem when Trump goes after
Gretta, Toon Berg as an individual seems to
sort of ridicule or even for the idiosyncrasies
that are part of her being mildly autistic.
When people go against her attack, her motives
or her demeanor, her physical appearance,
all this stuff, you're really saying that
that's the same as a word pun that had nothing
to do whatsoever with Baron Trump as a person.
You got to give me a break.
And then even more pathetic, by the way, is
that Trump's wife, the first lady, Melania
Trump, uh, has very publicly said her cause
is bullying.
She doesn't want bullying, she doesn't want
cyber bullying, she doesn't want school bullying
or any kind of bullying.
And then when the opportunity presents itself
where her husband is bullying Gretta Toon
Berg, she initially says nothing.
And then I believe I'm going from memory here,
actually said that Gretta sort of brought
it on herself in some way.
I don't actually, it was over the weekend
that I was so sick.
And by the mere concept of it, I didn't research
it, but said something along the lines of,
well, she did something to deserve the criticism.
These people don't get they the right claims
to be all about principles.
And then when they actually get an opportunity
to live their principles, it turns out that
it turns out that the principles don't even
matter remotely.
It's absolutely stunning and disgusting.
There is no comparison between attacking Gretta
burger the way Republicans have attacked her.
They are so triggered by her versus a language,
pun related to Barron Trump and a Baron of,
of, of royalty.
Uh, I don't even take the criticism seriously
and the, the only defense I've seen is a willing
versus unwilling public figure very easily
debunked.
Hubble.